tactic Soaker is a landmark game in the
evolution of the strategy RPG genre yet
it's never quite received the
appreciation it deserves outside of
Japan part of this has to do with the
long shadow cast by is directly inspired
and much beloved younger sibling Final
Fantasy Tactics despite receiving an
incredible remake in 2011 PSP
exclusivity once again limited the
audience for Tactics Ogre now with the
release of the HD and massively revamped
tactic Soaker reborn on every platform
Under the Sun Square Enix is taking
steps to correct a long-standing
Injustice though some quibbles with
presentation and gameplay changes keep
this from being the definitive version
of the all-time classic
foreign
follows young Denim and his sister
kashua two siblings of the wallister
clan the wallister have suffered under
the oppression of the ruling galistani
for years and a resistance movement has
begun to form among them what began as a
plan to avenge the death of their
siblings father snowballs into a mission
to rescue Duke Runway leader of the
resistance but his denim becomes part of
the growing resistance force he
discovers the lengths that Duke Runway
will go to advance his cause forcing him
to make very difficult choices as the
struggle expands to involved neighboring
states denim will need to find his own
way to put an end to the conflict if
you're familiar with previous works by
director and writer yasumi matsuno of
Final Fantasy Tactics vagrant story and
Final Fantasy 12 Fame you'll find
similar themes here intertwining
politics moral quandaries class
struggles and idealism gone awry
depending on the choices you make
including some absolutely gut-wrenching
life or death decisions the story's path
as well as Which special characters you
can recruit will change dramatically
there are plenty of twists and surprises
to experience enhanced by a combination
of a superb English script from feigned
localizer Alexander O Smith and the
addition of voice acting for cut scenes
the Wallace the Boon is great and our
future bright we are not alone in our
loyalty upon word of your Grace's
release many wallisters have left their
haunts for almorica the world Terrace
system from the PSP remake also returns
which acts as an enhanced New Game Plus
upon completing the game you can go back
to previous points in the story
exploring different outcomes and Roots
while keeping your current character
roster gameplay is similar to other
grid-based strategy RPGs you cultivate
and deploy a carefully selected mini
Army to battle against the
cpu-controlled squad by moving around
the battlefield and using attacks and
skills to gain the upper hand when each
character gets their turn and how far
they can move is determined by a
multitude of factors including stats
gear Buffs debuffs and how many actions
they took in their previous turn the
effectiveness of attacks and skills is
similarly affected by a wide degree of
variables stats Elemental affiliations
attack type and even which direction
you're approaching from are just a few
of the things that factor into crucial
decision making what makes combat fun is
the sheer amount of options is at your
disposal and variables to consider do
you go in Sword Swinging with your big
bruisers to draw the enemy towards you
or hold back until your MP resources
build up first do you go for sustained
smaller attacks on a Target or try to
weaken your foe with status elements
before going in for a massive killing
blow should you kill the monsters you
encounter to obtain rare items or
attempt to train them to use their
unique powers and battles moving forward
figuring out a way to approach each
fight and executing your plans or at
least attempting to is tremendously
rewarding and if mistakes are made
there's a way to take back particularly
bone-headed moves the charioterrid is an
optional feature you can activate to
rewind turns in battle and try a
different course of action but all the
rewinds in the world aren't going to
save you if you don't have a strong Army
to begin with and building up a platoon
of Heroes to your liking is one of the
most engaging and rewarding parts of
Tactics Ogre there are a myriad of
classes to discover throughout the game
from genre Staples like Mages Knights
and archers to fear inspiring Terror
nights Undead controlling necromancers
and the projectile specialist fusiliers
[Music]
each class has specific skills they can
learn and equip but only four can be
assigned per character you're not stuck
with a specific weapon type in each
class either all classes have at least a
few different weapons they can equip and
specific classes can utilize magic
spells too this flexibility means it's
possible to have multiple units of the
same class with a wildly different
builds for example you can make a ninja
unit focused on a combination of ranged
bow attacks and Ninjutsu magic alongside
another ninja character built for
dealing debilitating damage with dual
wield melee attacks that inflict status
ailments exploring the classes and
playing around with different
configurations is tremendously fun and
is easy to spend hours micromanaging
your virtual soldiers adding to this
experience are some revamped gameplay
mechanics that are brand new to Tactics
Ogre Reborn the systems for Learning and
utilizing skills have been streamlined
tremendously making it easy to keep
track of what characters have learned
and equipped new skills have been added
such as a skill for some classes that
triggers a follow-up pincer attack when
an opposing unit is surrounded and
attacked in addition instead of the
confusing and cumbersome class-based
leveling system of the PSP remake
characters now gain levels through a
more typical individual exp system where
each unit gains levels through exp that
carries over even after changing classes
another new addition charms are
single-use items that can boost
character stats raise their levels and
change their Elemental affiliations
giving you even more control over their
customization and if you want to build
up the levels and skills of a few units
you can choose to enter training battles
where the risk of permadeath is
mitigated that also means no more random
battles when roaming around the map
there are copious other changes in
quality of life upgrades to tactics over
reborn a trajectory viewer to see
exactly where ranged attacks will hit
the elimination of item crafting failure
a Revival system work in the Final
Fantasy Tactics with a countdown timer
on Fallen units until permadeath and
being able to scout the battlefield
before combat most of these alterations
are for the better but there are a few
that are debatably worse the addition of
randomly appearing buff and debuff cars
to collect or try to force upon foes on
the battlefield is a neat idea though
can wind up making battles more chaotic
not to mention messy when they've
sprouted all over the arena skills and
finishing moves that use their resource
called TP in the PSP game now I'll use
MP instead this makes Resource
Management slightly easier but also
makes managing MP resources much more
challenging for certain classes like the
healing slash tank hybrid nights finally
one of the biggest changes is the
introduction of a party-wide level cap
that only increases once you've cleared
particular parts of the story this is
done to prevent you from over leveling
the Beast story battles while it helps
keep the challenge level consistent it
prevents a player that is having trouble
in a particular encounter from grinding
to help overcome it which they should
have the freedom to do if they please
the other major issue is the visuals
while the high resolution character
portrait artwork looks fantastic the
upscaling of the Sprite art leaves
something to be desired as it looks like
a particularly bad filter has been
applied I got used to it after a while
but compared to amazing HD 2D reworkings
like live a live another Square Enix
title tactics over reborn feels plain by
comparison certain music selections have
been redone as well but the emphasis on
heavy orchestration takes away some of
the intense melodic qualities of the
previous Renditions the ability to
switch to more authentic pixely Graphics
or use previous soundtracks would have
been a great addition
but alas tactics ogre's intense tactical
combat in-depth character building and
excellent storytelling makes it a must
play for strategy RPG fans it's
wonderful that this game is a much more
widely available now and most of the
updates and upgrades make the package
even better while some might bulk at the
50 price tag for a remake with an iffy
graphical and sound overhaul the superb
strategy gameplay and branching story
paths will keep your attention for a
very long time while it might not be a
perfect remake it's a damn good one
tell his grace that he struggle with the
galgastani is of no concern to his
Eminence abouna Branton nor is it any
concern of ours
the knights Los lorian remain and shall
remain neutral on the matter my thanks
sir for your Swift response